one Williams a reporter with the
Washington Post and the author of a book
called eyes on the prize America's Civil
Rights years 54 through 65 we've gone
beyond the Voting Rights Act civil
rights legislation what is the prize
that blacks eyes are on in 1987 I think
the movement has changed in eyes on the
prize the book and I might add it's also
a PBS television series what we're
looking at is the prize of really
freedom and dignity and we're working
toward the Voting Rights Act and of
course the Civil Rights Act in 64 but
now I think the movement is moved to a
new phase and really we're talking about
an economic and political struggle we
see that blacks are more concerned with
things like affirmative action than they
are with public accommodation so
hopefully the public accommodations
issue has been settled and really what
we're talking about is getting blacks
into the mainstream of American life
giving them some equity in terms of the
nation's economic wealth and getting
them some part of the nation's political
power this is the book we're going to be
talking about today eyes on the prize
America's civil rights years 54 through
65 Juan Williams our guest wrote the
book and it is a companion book to a
six-part PBS series currently airing I
think they're in the fourth episode I
believe on third episode third episode
on PBS all about the civil rights years
now you were too young to have marched
in marches like this was an interesting
and educational experience someone like
you who is benefited from these marches
benefited from the civil rights movement
but you really didn't participate was it
a unique experience preparing for this
it really was and I must say that I was
looking at some Census Bureau numbers as
I was coming to the end of that book and
realized that over half of the country
now was born after this period so that
people really have a dim recollection of
it and may not realize what immediate
history it is this is not distant
history it's not distant that Rosa Parks
had to put her dime in the front of the
bus get off and walk to the back door
and get in the back that's sort of
strict segregation and legal legally
enforced segregation is recent in our
country's history and still has impact
on blacks and whites Julian Bond writes
the introduction for the book quoting
from about the second page of Julian
bonds introduction
quote first it takes readers beyond this
book referring to this book first it
takes readers beyond the popular belief
that a few larger-than-life figures such
as Martin Luther King jr. and John F
Kennedy were the movements most
important players that is not to
diminish these men but as you will learn
they were not solely responsible for
this era of its successes tell us about
some of those heroes that were not as
familiar with a car I think one of my
favorite ones is a woman named Joanne
Robinson in Montgomery Alabama Joanne
Robinson was just got tired of the
situation on the buses where black women
were referred to as Apes by the bus
drivers where she was physically
threatened for accidentally sitting in a
seat front seat of an empty bus and she
formed something called a women's
political Council in Montgomery she was
teaching at Alabama State so there was
some threat to her as a result of that
because potentially the state government
or the city government could cut off
funds to Alabama State but she persisted
and in her persistence she got the Rosa
Parks involved with the Youth Council
she got the n-double a-c-p in a man and
meeting Nixon involved and as a result
of her efforts Rosa Parks finally
refuses to stand up and move to the back
of the bus one day and when Parks is
arrested and that whole movement begins
then we get the stage on which a man
like Martin Luther King can stand and
rise to prominence but it's really the
work of the little people down below
Edie Nixon Joanne Robinson that gets
things going and that's the same story I
might add throughout the movement
you'll see it in terms of the students
in the sit-ins and the Freedom Rides you
see it time and again little people in
many places many put in many places at
different times making the movement work
is there a real interest at this point
America 1987 in the civil rights
movement of 54 to 65 you find an
interest well you know I think there is
a tremendous interest and you know in
fact what's happened recently in
Cummings Georgia and Howard Beach New
York is almost tailor-made to sort of
reawaken the American consciousness
about the problems of race in our
society but in fact I don't think we
need too much of a reminder one of the
ironies of writing this book at this
time is that it hasn't been done before
here we have what I think is sort of the
quintessential moment of modern American
history the civil rights movement really
a remarkable movement that confirms our
trust in our Constitution our laws our
lawmakers
federal officials and people have sort
of shied away from it because I think
they perceive it as a violent sort of
time to be dismissed and forgotten I
think really it's a glorious time and I
wish more people would pay attention to
it the lot of talk about race racism in
America
news magazines wherever you look really
this is a new republic the issue for
February 9 1987 as you can see after
Howard Beach racism and the politics of
racial confrontation and I'm going to
move to the inside and look at the first
paragraph written by the editors of New
Republic and it says quote legally and
institutionally and in its collective
image of itself the United States is no
longer a racist society the civil rights
movement smashed the apparatus of
segregation and political exclusion
irreversible achievement that brought
America's civil structures civil
structures in the line with its civil
religion of equality and tolerance that
social revolution has continued to score
new gains ever since perhaps middle
class that has moved out of the ghetto
and into mainstream American life these
achievements are we're celebrating but
not just now would you agree with that
first paragraph yes I think the reason
that it's not worth celebrating right
now is that we have too much racial
confrontation going on in the country I
think that much of the racial
confrontation we have of course is
different I think that point needs to be
made it's not really about public
accommodations or breaking down the
legal segregation system that system has
been broken down and all do you know
praises due to the fact that that was
done from 654 to 65 but what we have
right now that the editors of New
Republic are referring to is really this
fight over things like affirmative
action busing and of course we have
these ugly incidents in Howard Beach and
down in Cummings Georgia and we have to
really understand that racism is still
with us that these are recent events in
terms of overcoming this legal
segregation and the nation still has to
deal with this past it's not the case I
think is our president might say that we
have a colorblind society in which
everyone sort of competes the equally
and we need not pay any attention to
race we still need to pay attention to
race and to get it out of our system you
talked about some of they are the prize
for modern blacks being economic Jesse
Jackson and his standard stump speech
use of the line from racial battleground
found economic common ground and on the
moral higher ground talk more about that
what is the economic status of blacks
how well offer blacks in America well I
think that if you look at the numbers
just in pure terms blacks earn about
fifty seven fifty eight cents to the
dollar for whites that's the basic
comparison now there's some problems
with those numbers the first problem of
course is that blacks are have become
essentially two classes you have an
expanding middle class with blacks doing
much better there they are in the high
eighty cents to the dollar for whites
that's compared to whites while you have
that sort of underclass and the inner
cities poor blacks who are being denied
Economic Opportunity educational
opportunity job training and so forth
and they earn much less than they
dragged down that dollar total that's
why you get that fifty eight cents of
the dollar but the fact remains that
blacks earn less than whites in this
country and I think that if you look at
the real wealth of the country you'll
see that blacks have less than one
percent of the real economic wealth in
the country you come to understand that
they really do not share in this
country's economic bounty the most
recent issue of Harper's Magazine I'll
have to trust me I think I'll show you
here most recent issue of Harper's
magazine February 87 as a piece called
moving up at last and it's basically
sort of a roundtable discussion with one
Williams Glenn Lowry Julian Bond Paula
Giddings and Frank
Mingo if I move to the inside they're
discussing black America 1987 and mr.
Lowry makes this comment referring to
what's called the black bush law which
was e black people who were prejudiced
against the black poor even within my
own family I've heard stories about
relatives who wouldn't talk to other
relatives because they were quote poor
ass [ __ ] end of quote they lived on
the wrong side of town they couldn't
come to the party talking about the
problems of economics do we have these
two classes poor blacks and maybe
well-off wise I think it is a problem
and you know I think that the in course
of writing eyes on the price it became
apparent to me that really the way that
people went about the civil rights
movement was not impromptu people had
strategies and decided how best to make
the movement work and similarly we can
look at some of those strategies today
for problems we have at the underclass
and poor blacks and I think in
particular the middle class blacks have
a real obligation
to help to go back and do things that
could possibly help sort of raise the
bottom up get em the black underclass
into a position where it can move up
economically in this discussion you have
this comment to say talking about the
problems of blacks economic in
particular quote if the problem for
middle-class back
blacks has shifted from access to
empowerment does that mean the old old
civil rights strategies aren't valid
anymore how did you answer that question
I think the old civil rights strategies
aren't valid anymore because really the
oh so the right strategies have to do
with sort of protest for public
accommodations and had to do with sort
of demanding your that the nation
enforce your legal rights as an American
citizen under the Constitution I think
that battle has been won I think the
fight now is really one sort of inside
corporations inside City Hall's inside
state capitals one inside the big
corporations and I do not think that in
every case that it still rights March is
going to get you a you know your share
of the pie good morning and welcome to
our Colin program each morning at this
time we invited journalists to join us
here in our studios on Capitol Hill talk
about some of the issues that they have
been covering today we're going to talk
about civil rights on our guest as Juan
Williams author of the book we've been
referring to called eyes on the prize
he's a writer with the Washington Post
he's been with the post since 1976 he's
currently working on the Washington Post
magazine comes out on Sundays here in
Washington Williams took a one-year
sabbatical to write the book before that
he covered social and political issues
from the national desk the White House
and the 1986 or 1984 1986 Democratic
campaign in college he worked at the
Philadelphia Bulletin and the Providence
Rhode Island Journal he has a BA in
philosophy from Haverford College
where's that right outside of
Philadelphia Pennsylvania and he is
originally from New York City New York
this is the book we're talking about and
it's a companion book to the PBS series
six-part PBS series eyes on the prize I
just start to write this as a large book
there's a lot in this clearly a lot of
interviews we're just start you took a
year walk us through how someone writes
a book like this well in part you have
to realize that it's sort of an unusual
venture in that the film version of eyes
on the prize came first I was called by
the man who was producing the films was
interested in sort of seeing who he
wanted to write this book and looking at
the structure how would you tell the
story I think was one of the first
questions he had for me and when I laid
it out for him I think that we found we
were in sympathy in terms of approach
that we would take some material and
from that point on I started looking
first at what he had in terms he had
gone back to many of the archival
materials taken from CBS and ABC looking
where television news to really cut its
teeth on the civil rights movement
understood how to use the camera in fact
developed by what is now the evening
news format that going from 15 to 30
minutes and really telling the civil
rights story in fact some people would
argue that the television cameras and
reporters became advocates for civil
rights because they would spread news of
the movement and when they did so it
would involve the Justice Department the
president because it suddenly became a
national news story so really we start
looking at that archival footage start
looking at people who are still alive
today who can tell stories about the
movement going back to Ralph Abernathy
going back to a needy Nixon arose and
Parkes started to collect that material
and then you find that at some point the
film materials value drops off because
the book of course spans more time and
goes into greater depth and what
archival footage is available so you
start going back to the Schomburg
collection in new york the more on
Spingarn library at Howard University
the Kennedy Library the Eisenhower
library looking for really the details
and little points of that era that
wonderful rich story that we have in our
national history and that's how the book
came to be how much traveling did you
have to do in the south did you go back
to some of the sites of these major
major Civil War battles no no no I
didn't I didn't in some cases the film
people had been down there most often
because of the intense deadline for this
book what I had to do was to call down
and speak speak to people and go
interview people individually more so
than simply go to the sites of the
battle did you find that people do still
remember and calling and asking about
you talk about the people who remember
different things do people still have a
very clear image and know a lot about
what happened it's incredible and I
think that's one of the greater values
of this I I think the greatest value of
the whole project is that young people
today we can have a sense of the
movement and a good historical
perspective on it but I think one other
great thing about it
many of these people now are getting
very old and for them it was absolutely
the apex of their lives I mean the
definitely defining moments in their
existence with their participation in
the civil rights movement and for so
many of them they want to tell their
story and they want the story to be told
in an honest and compassionate way you
talked about how the news media even
back in 1964 63 65 almost were almost
advocates in the sense that they spread
the news of what was going on what about
today in 1987 this is a Time magazine
spread covering the March the week after
what happened in Forsyth County Georgia
a big spread got a lot of attention as
the media do the same today I don't
think the media does it nearly as much
the media has sort of lost its
preoccupation with civil rights I looked
back at the as I did in the course of
the research rise on the price you look
back at the New York Times Time magazine
the Arkansas Gazette in other papers the
Atlanta Constitution and you see that
these papers were in the forefront of
the movement in the sense that these
were people taking great risk against
the segregationist culture against their
advertisers and cut some cases to stand
and say this is a horrible thing
happening in our country a cancer spread
and we need to pay attention to it and
deal with it and I think for the most
part the press has gone along with the
Reagan years which is to sort of move
sort of a interest in civil rights and
see it as a past history rather than a
sort of continuous issues for us to deal
with since this is a program about
journalism what was the role of the
editors of southern newspapers in civil
rights movements just key you know I for
the most part the editors were not party
to the segregationist line for the most
part and I think of people like Harry
Ashworth the Arkansas Gazette and I
think of people like hiding Carter in
Mississippi I think of the Atlanta
Constitution these papers absolutely
stood strong it's incredible that they
did it at great risk we're not talking
about getting the guys at some mall
angry as we might today we're talking
about the entire town threatening to
withdraw its support for a newspaper and
these editors doing so standing tall our
guest Juan Williams author of this book
eyes on the prize discussing discussing
the civil rights movement 54 to 65 and
also 19
seven forward Texas your first caller
this morning go ahead please yes you
know the gun forward but there were
members of families that were save on it
twenty years now we've had integration
and the same opportunity with a lot of
aid also nothing there was there wasn't
really that many slave on us and those
that I have wronged and dead the people
those people enjoyed you don't represent
the United States a bunch jerk everybody
knows that a small bunch of jerks
we are plenty you we feel like
everybody's alive but we don't
understand how much longer them the
people have got to be all they've got to
be discriminated against because they're
white like with the affirmative action
these people that are being denied even
though they're more qualified it's sort
of like your social promotion what good
did it do to give you social promotion
and I found application not you sir I'm
talking about what good did it do to
give minorities social promotions in the
school and now they can still have a job
for applications ok Texas alcohol coming
well I think that she's right when she
says that the people in Cummings Georgia
or you know maybe even Howard Beatrice
somewhat anachronistic sort of out of
place and out of time with the way
they're treating black people down there
the fact is that no blacks live in the
county and black a sort of unofficially
banned from walking down the middle of
the street that's pretty bizarre in our
modern America but she deals with what I
think is really the modern movement a
much more complicated subject which is
for instance affirmative action or
preferential treatment in terms of
hiring or maybe even admission to
schools and that's a tough one that the
nation still having to deal with because
things are not equal between blacks and
whites in this country a moment ago we
were talking about the economic
differences so the question is how do
you make recompense for these past
problems how do you try to build up this
minority group that has been so severely
disadvantaged and I think that's
something that the country needs of
leadership on and I don't think the
leadership has been provide
these last six years under mr. Reagan
Tacoma Washington go ahead please I'm
having a problem listening to what is
happening currently but with regards to
affirmative action I'd like mr. Williams
to respond to the white person's view
that affirmative action has gone a
little bit too far on that black persons
are now enjoying a disadvantage in a few
categories where before there was a
little bit of just justice well I think
that what the caller needs to take into
consideration is sort of specific
instances first of all you should know
that affirmative action in no case calls
for the hiring of people who are not
qualified for a job
what affirmative action calls for as we
understand it here in Washington Justice
Department even in the Reagan
administration understands it is the
hiring of qualified black people for
jobs making those jobs available to
black people and sort of ensuring the
companies go out and recruit blacks and
make an applicant pool included black
people so that you don't get the
situation where company says well we
didn't have any blacks we don't know any
blacks who could have done this job when
in fact blacks who are fully capable do
exist and simply aren't getting the
opportunities so that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
affirmative action but I think that many
people excuse me
think of abuses of the system and think
of a situation let's say in colleges the
colleges are a place now where we're
seeing more and more incidents of racial
racism and I think in large part it's
because the students perceive that black
some black students are getting in there
with lower grades or some students may
not be as qualified to be in the schools
not as smart not able as their caller
said may be a fill out an application
and they are nonetheless still getting
in this very competitive school well let
me just say this I think that in fact
that situation is being overdrawn much
in the way that we might over draw the
you know welfare queen the pink Cadillac
there are problems there are it is the
fact that the educational achievement
for blacks might be somewhat less than
it is for whites but when you look at a
school you not only want to get a racial
mix in that school you want to get also
maybe kids will alumni you want to get
musicians you want to get athletes and
that's the way that that group is
selected and I don't think that blacks
mean apologize for
given opportunities because they are
blacks Peoria Illinois good morning go
ahead please yes I have a question which
I would like answered by anybody in
Washington or in Illinois and that is
how can any group of quote legislators
unquote at any level of government
rationalized that by non action rather
than action they should be entitled to
an increase in pay equal to or higher
than the yearly income of the majority
of their constituents does this applies
to whites blacks Hispanics anything so
you're opposed to theories they're
talking about in Congress definitely am
and I think that this is the synthesis
of first chance I get to get into c-span
I feel that this is the an appropriate
time because this question has to be
answered today okay thank Suzanne
waiting till tomorrow Wednesday I think
yeah floor you'll see on the floor of
the house at a debate on a very issue in
some sort of a conclusion on that you're
going to watch c-span any comment on
that you know I think it's one of the
interesting debates in Washington right
now because some people would argue that
if you're a lawyer a big law firm in
town you can make $150,000 but if you
decide that you want to be involved with
the Congress you can't expect to make
that much money and people talk about
struggling to make it I'm $70,000 I
think the caller's right to be concerned
they look sort of developing an elite
here Jenner California go ahead please
yes I'm just calling just to uh I have a
disabled veteran white I protested join
the 60 I did go to Vietnam in 68 I was
involved in the March 5 and 64 in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania the Hill
District now I have as a disabled person
and I've been able to get a job in a
black person who has the same
qualifications I do
except it's not disabled the flash
gets the job over me and the same thing
goes with Hispanic and I go online here
in California with the different
nationalities and I just feel that we
have we were forgetting that there were
white people out there that we're doing
a lot to help blacks get the right
because they have gotten to this point
and now they're being neglected and the
blacks and minorities are stepping
forward and saying we still haven't got
our just do when do we they pay this
balance where it's somewhat balanced and
we're working in that direction and stop
pushing the issue and start letting more
people back into the work force
California sanctions a call I think the
caller asks a critical question which is
how do you know when the country becomes
reaches some sense of equilibrium on
this raised question and I'm not sure if
there is an answer at this point what I
can say is that I know we're not at that
point now I think if we look at the
economics of the situations we were
discussing if you look at the
educational attainment of them two races
if you look at the opportunities the two
races have for job training so forth
you'll see that it's not equal but the
problem becomes one where people
especially I think working class and
sort sort of lower middle class White's
feel that their opportunities are being
impinged upon by the preference given to
these blacks so why these blacks given
these jobs that I didn't own slaves in
fact I might have even been a supporter
of the civil rights movement and they
feel somewhat put upon by any suggestion
that blacks should be given some
preferential treatment or affirmative
action edge and hiring or education etc
I think that's unfortunate because the
country is still working through this
legacy of racism this is the country
that not only had legal slavery let's
say a hundred years ago this is the
country that until recently you see this
an Izone price the book until recently
had a legal system of legally enforced
segregation these are harsh the harsh
restriction of put on a group of people
it affects not only their
professionalizing careers and education
it affects their family life it leads to
sort of a breakdown of values it is a
horrible horrible thing that have been
has been done to blacks in this country
and it's not simply to say that
now therefore the doors should be open
and everything should be given the
blacks but I think it's simply that
taking into getting this historical
context into consideration you
understand that the problem is with us
and the problem is still being worked
out and it's not when we can make sort
of easy lines and say everything's over
blacks have public accommodation so
let's just go forward we do not have a
colorblind society when one thing to the
civil rights movement of the South in
the early 60s late 50s you think of
black black and white confrontation in
1987 the largest growing minority in the
country is Hispanic by 1981 I guess they
will be the largest minority Asian
population growing how does that change
the civil rights movement if you will in
America today there's the growing number
of Hispanics and also Asians competing
with blacks it changes the equation
greatly in terms of the political
balance because suddenly you have a
situation where Hispanics can be played
off against blacks or the Hispanic vote
against the black vote against the Asian
vote but in fact the country has a
special relationship with blacks again
because this history will referring to
again because of what we write about and
seeing eyes on the prize blacks and
whites in America there is a special
relationship there is a marriage and in
the sense that the country no other
minority or ethnic group can really ever
lay claim to sort of that particular
dynamic which has been ugly at times
Laureus at times and when that sort of
segregation ends but nonetheless a
defining moment in our nation's history
Fairfax Virginia go ahead please yes mr.
Williams I think one of the reasons that
the civil rights movement today has kind
of spoiled basically in white America I
think there's a couple of reasons the
first one I think is the overuse of the
word racism in the sense that most white
people would probably agree that there
are still in justices that should be
corrected but if you listen to any forum
of black newspaper people black
politicians anyone who does not 100%
totally agree with the black agenda is a
racist and any black person who dares
disagree with any thing that Jesse
Jackson says is an awful Tom and white
people are really
a little bit sticker here in that arm
you know it's not only white people I
think black people a little sick of
hearing that I I think that black people
have a strong reaction to that kind of
you know demagoguery what you see in a
situation like that is a tendency for
people to believe that really you can't
have disagreements among blacks that
race is still such an issue in our
society even if racism per se is not but
race is still such an issue because of
the differences between the two races
that really we should subsume all our
differences all our private arguments
where blacks are arguing about each
other about what's the best strategy et
cetera and simply back each other up to
the point where you get black supporting
maybe leaders that aren't the best
leaders where you get situations that
might be even prove embarrassing but I
don't think that that's the reason for
people therefore as we were saying
people getting sick and tired of this to
excuse the fact that there is a real
problem in this country with race and
it's a real problem needs to be
addressed and remains it's a real
problem that you can see when you go
into an area where you can see the black
underclass living in sort of deprived
conditions where you see young black
people not getting educational
opportunities we have fewer and fewer
black people going to college today
there's a real problem to be dealt with
and it should not be diminished by any
excess of a black politician or the fact
that blacks tend to feel they need to
all stand in line together because they
have great insecurity about their future
in this country you covered the 1984
presidential race our caller brought up
the Reverend Jesse Jackson what is the
Reverend Jesse Jackson's role as far as
speaking on behalf of blacks well I
think the Jesse Jackson has a prime role
in the mass of blacks because I think
the media Tunes in the Jesse I know that
I as a reporter I'm asked to by my
editors regularly tune into Jesse
Jackson as sort of a spokesman for black
Americana in a political sense I think
in the 84 election Jackson proved that
he is extremely popular and some people
would get him the title president of
black America because he went into many
cities and one despite the fact that the
black mirror got or local politicians
would go for Mondale people felt a real
sense of pride in Jesse Jackson they saw
in Jesse Jackson a black man running
for the presidency of the United States
and felt a strong sense of pride and I
think the Jesse Jackson is going to run
again in 88 and I think you may see
someone think of a repeat of that
although I think this time maybe a
little bit of a charm has rubbed off in
terms of the media Jackson will get I
think less coverage this time although
he's more likely to do sort of
grandstand plays this time because
really I don't think he's looking
forward to a run in 92 or anything like
that I think that basically this is it
for Jesse Jackson there's a Southern
Regional primary was it handwritten
hand-delivered to Jesse Jackson well it
sure looks like it I think that
Jackson's going to do very well if he
doesn't win that thing I think he is a
good shot to come in second and it's
going to get his campaign off to a big
start the question is how we'll do
elsewhere in the country and I don't
can't imagine he'll ever equal the fact
that he will come in first or second in
the southern primary where the majority
of this country's black people in
Seattle Washington go ahead please yes
mr. Wilson
I recently moved from New York City I
heard convention and how it beats racial
racial incident earlier in the show I
think this is out of whack with the
national figures on crime I have two
books in front of me
one is report to the nation on crime and
justice and the other is criminal
victimization in the USA both by the
Justice Department and they show very
clearly that in the 1534 age group among
males the black part white attacks is
nine point two to one and in general
it's seven point nine to one and rape
black non-white rape is 35 to one now
these things are what brings about
racism in my opinion I left New York to
get away from this sort of thing and if
you want to be treated with the equal
civil rights you have to have civilized
conduct if this is not going on right
now well you have to understand I think
that first of all what you have is a
situation in let's say New York where
you have poor blacks living in proximity
to people with money you have a
situation where really there's strain on
the class system as much as it is on the
race system that you have classes of
poor blacks there the classes there the
rich and middle class whites and the
strains start the show and you also have
a situation where people who
have economic opportunity people who
don't have educational training resort
to any means whatsoever to get money and
this is another legacy and a horrible
legacy of our civil rights struggles in
this country but I think that therefore
just appointed crime were to say that
blacks are not civil etc it's a mistake
look but really the result for the cause
the cause is not that blacks are any
less human or any less civil the cause
is lack of opportunity can't can
Connecticut excuse me good morning go
ahead please
good morning I wanted to talk about
blacks and their opportunities
I can only equate it to the Irish which
I happen to be one that came to this
country my parents when they came here
there was very little opportunity in
fact they used to be signs outside
factories Irish Catholics need not apply
now I'm not acquitting that to what's
happening for all these many many years
to Black's because blacks are very
visible I know a lot of people who
applied for jobs who were Irish
Catholics have put down that they were
English in order to get work but I think
that the blacks are making one big
mistake and that is they're going for
higher education and then getting decent
jobs and leaving the others behind there
are the Irish worked at a different way
they got into the police department in
New York and they got into various
low-level jobs despite the fact that
they might have had a degree for the
morality of the colleges and they
brought the others along with them I had
a cousin I can remember who was going to
college at nights who was a walking a
beat in my neighborhood they eventually
became the mayor in New York up through
the system but here in order to do that
he got into a political party and worked
and worked and worked with a lot of
patience and took years to do it what's
happening in my opinion is the blacks
who get a fairly good education they
leave the others behind the Irish did
not do that they brought the others up
with them then the Italians came they
could say of course by that time the
police department was pretty full they
went into the Sanitation Department in
New York City and brought the others
along with them that's not happening
you say your cousin became the mayor of
New York but that you became the mayor
of New York why yes he was one of the
mayors of New York and he'd come that he
came to this country with the equivalent
of a high school education and it took
them seven years to get through college
by working it very very slowly well I
know I agree with you I think that
really the next step is to find how
middle-class blacks can become more
involved with the issues and problems
facing blacks who are poor and who are
disadvantaged in this country we have an
expanding middle class in country and
it's necessary for middle-class black
people like myself really to involve
themselves and I think that's the
challenge I think that's the new
frontier for organizations like the
n-double-a-cp the Urban League we were
talking a minute ago Carl about whether
or not the old strategies from the civil
rights years apply today the old
strategies used in right about my eyes
on the prize I don't know if they apply
but I know that those organizations
n-double-a-cp openly etc still have a
role to play and the role may be getting
middle-class blacks involved lafayette
california go ahead please i'm hearing
me as a white woman i'm hearing an awful
lot of white person's expressing racism
even parlours the guy probably in their
own hearts but i want really called
about the congress race and how to my
mind that would put those giant raises
would call into action all the white
males who are professional lawyers all
over the country to come and run for
congress and my recollection of my
history was that the early Congress has
had farmers and tradesmen
they didn't have to be lawyers you can
always hire a lawyer if you have an idea
for your county or your district you can
always hire a lawyer to write out the
law for you I just feel that this is
this Congress race will discriminate
against women and minorities who are
very capable already who could fill
those jobs quite well because of the
power that a white male has in the
society whether he likes it or not
us okay the upper classes among the
good-old-boy came among the fellows
who've been the school of Sandford maybe
its affair and whether they they may not
realize it but it's fair
Lafayette California thanks recall any
comments well I think you know it's what
we talked about earlier I think it's a
real strong point I appreciate what she
said about the farmers and tradesmen who
used to run in the Congress and be in
Congress you don't see too many of them
anymore talking about a book by one
Williams eyes on the prize accompanying
a six-part PBS series talking about the
civil rights movement also blacks in
1987 in America there's this story and
talking about economics as far as the
next challenge for black America its
welfare revision held a top issue on
agenda of Nations governor's Maureen
Dowd writes a story Dateline Washington
governor Michael Castle Delaware said
today that revision of the nation's
welfare system was being transformed
from an unpopular and seemingly
insoluble problem to an issue at the top
of the governor's agenda for the next
two years now this was also something
that President Reagan brought up and
it's something that is a point of
contention within the black community
itself is it is welfare creating this
entry imprisoning and enforcing blacks
to stay poor what's what is the feeling
and what are the different arguments on
as far as welfare in black America well
I think that one of the predominant
arguments one put forth by Charles
Murray and his what I think is an
important book called losing ground is
that the welfare system has served to
encourage black men to leave their homes
encourage young black women to have
babies out of wedlock because once you
have the illegitimate child it really
opens up a plethora of social programs
for you in terms of housing and medical
care et cetera and his book has been
taken as sort of a sign that the welfare
system is in disrepair and I think the
system has its problems I'm not sure
that he has any solutions though and the
question is where do we go from here how
do we make a welfare system that really
encourages people to go to work
encourages people to care for themselves
and gives them a sense of dignity we
have the same problem I might add with
our housing in terms of sort of putting
people into housing projects that really
are sad places to live and encourage
people to live in ways that do not
that aren't productive that don't get
them into work that don't get them there
into strong family situations now the
many suggestions abounding one of them
comes out of Massachusetts the most
popular one governor Dukakis there has a
program in which he works the program is
called ET educational training and and
and what you do is there sort of tie the
welfare program to a training program so
that people get training while they're
on well thing idea is that they get off
welfare as a result of the training but
these were clear programs as they're
called are becoming more popular
throughout the nation and hopefully they
are the future of welfare Indianapolis
Indiana go ahead please yes thank you
car give me this look Chesterfield a
little bit and I want to comment those
two last two colors there that this Pope
would state especially Irish gentleman
and uh I do think myself I'm a black
American I do thank myself that a lot of
our blacks they gets it they go and get
their education doctors lawyers and
because I know but we got quite a few
Indian Anna and they forget about the
low man and uh thinking you know kind of
hit him up a little bit you know if I
don't have a fifteen thousand dollar fee
to pay a lawyer why can't he charged me
$5,000 I just listened to the other
night last night matter of fact that you
deserve another seventy sixers service
he could give me to retire and so I
don't have nothing against the Salvation
Army it's a good organization as far as
I know but he is donating out of
thousand dollars a quote unquote now to
or to the Salvation Army now we have
Boys Clubs here we have girls club here
and I can see why that money can't be
spent where it can't help the poor well
I think it but not well I think the
Salvation Army does help poor people and
does help minority people but I hear
what you're saying when you talk about
really where we're going as a country
and the idea being that you know lawyers
and and other people lawmakers I think
that's one thing we're hearing in the
calls this morning me be losing touch
with the common man and
or man in part because of large salaries
and where they have their you know their
values placement value maybe on nice
suits as opposed to helping people
talked about a successful black julius
erving many successful blacks in the
National Basketball Association that a
good is that a good or bad role model
for blacks I think that it's an
interesting thing in this country right
now we have The Cosby Show which is very
popular in an image of sort of
successful blacks we have things like
Julius Erving or you know sports heroes
who are black and who I think idolized
by black and white alike in this country
I don't really see much of a problem
there the problem comes in though when
that symbolism of a Cosby let's say is
taken to mean that everything is ok that
blacks don't have a problem in this
country blacks have an equal opportunity
to be successful live in a house have a
nice family you know and leave the good
life that's a lie and when you get that
kind of thing into the national psyche
as a sort of misperception of the
reality of life in America for black
people it becomes a danger and I think
that that's one danger we need to avoid
for instance the highest-paid man in
Washington DC was recently revealed as
Moses Malone was the center for the
Washington Bullets that doesn't mean
that the black people in Washington are
leading the highlights and in fact I
would argue to the contrary
Seattle Washington go ahead please yeah
good morning good morning to you um you
know I I don't think it's a matter of
whether you're white black green purple
blue Hispanic or whatever I think you
know what you need to do is we've got a
problem okay we've got some
disadvantaged whites
we've got disadvantaged blacks and other
races and maybe what you know the real
thing here is is here we've got some
people who need some help and you know
deal with the the situation as a total
picture you know let's all the
disadvantaged people let's take them all
as a group and say okay this is what you
know let's do this
you know let's would send you to school
let's get you educated and then when
they are educated in and they've got a
start in life and a place to go then you
know it's when I go out fridge
of it you know the best qualified person
gets the job you know and go from there
well I think that the college right you
know I think that's what the caller made
the misunderstanding something I think
it is the case that when you go out for
a job the best person doesn't get the
job if they're black people in the pool
of applicants they're all qualified in
you're qualified and people are I think
paying as much attention to the
qualifications in terms of whether or
not you can help them make money as
anything they don't no one out here not
the government is not saying anyone you
need to have a certain number of blacks
on the job or you can't make money
really they're looking at make the money
and have qualified people who are black
on the job so it's a matter of
competition among qualified people and
getting blacks into that pool but you
know the danger in saying that everybody
is equal it's all okay because once we
take care of people across the races is
that you might stop to think that they
really are racial problems in the
country you might begin to ignore them
and then you can't ignore them and
really our racial problem in this
country but I appreciate one point you
make which is that we need to address
the problems be they black or white for
poor people in the country and I think
the ones we get to that point and we
really can't start to move beyond race
Lexington Kentucky go ahead please yes
how you done very good in yourself
pretty good mister we have a couple
questions for you first
concerning the Kennedys I was wondering
how accurate the portrayal is of the
Kennedys of being great friends and
black people in the fifth John Kennedy
had lived and pulled and I've served his
full eight years and Robert Kennedy had
lived and they served the next eight
years after that do you think things
would be much different today for blood
people and secondly do you believe the
official explanation of the murder of
dr. Martin Luther King thank you very
much thank you for calling well I think
that the Kennedys are now sort of mythic
in in American life about the role they
played in terms of the civil rights
movement and I think in large part it's
deserved but I think that there's some
parts of it that aren't known for
instance when John Kennedy was running
for office
not many people realized that he was
very frank and telling people that he
knew nothing about
blackseed really had not had any black
friends or didn't wasn't aware of the
movement and coming from Massachusetts
and that he really said he had to come
up to speed on the issue and was
reluctant to get involved in fact took
advantage of the fact that many people
in the South were angry at Eisenhower
and at Richard Nixon Eisenhower's vice
president who was Kennedy's opponent
because Eisenhower had sent troops in
the Little Rock to protect the rights of
those students going into Little Rock
High so initially both Nixon and Kennedy
try to stay away from anything to do
with civil rights but in the course of
this the sit-in movement is going on in
1960 and Martin Luther King jr. is
arrested at Rich's department store in
Atlanta and when King was arrested a
deal is worked out initially get all the
sit-in people out of jail but King as
hell because he had a long-standing
violation for driving without a driver's
license so he sent away to a
penitentiary and put to hard work as a
result of that some calls get made one
of them is from Richard Nixon to the
Justice Department asking can we get
King out of jail or civil rights being
violated anyway well not much as made of
that but later some of Kennedy's aides
urged the presidential candidate to call
Coretta Scott King and indeed he does
that and when he does that that call
that sort of personal touch
it's publicized widely by the Kennedy
campaign throughout the black community
and as a result the black vote swings
toward Kennedy and when Kennedy comes
into office Kennedy time and time again
is confronted by the realities of the
civil rights movement going on and
Robert Kennedy I would say Robert
Kennedy really proves himself to be a
hero of the movement because Robert
Kennedy keeps up with the situation
keeps up with a James Meredith and
stands by the rights of blacks even
reluctantly and and helps blacks and the
movement to continue by supporting their
rights as black citizens as black
Americans under the Constitution so
really when we talk about the Kennedys
we have to understand that they were
people who at first were reluctant to
get involved and for political reasons
found that they prefer to stay out of it
but when pressed they did support the
United States Constitution as a document
that entitled all Americans with a black
or white to their rights in this country
this is inside of your book
eyes on the prize one Williams there's a
picture of Lyndon Johnson July 2nd 1964
signing a lot of the Civil Rights Act
many of us including myself saw on
Sunday night the portrayal of Lyndon
Baines Johnson it talked about his role
in this and the Voting Rights Act what
was always going to Johnson's roles for
other civil rights movement Lyndon
Johnson had a key role now the book eyes
on the prize goes from 54 to 65
Johnson's role continues past that time
but even in that period we see that
right after Kennedy's assassination
Johnson could have pulled back but
instead Johnson pushes forward and uses
Kennedy's assassination to say to the
people in Congress to the congressman
that we need to have to pass the civil
rights bill as a monument to John
Kennedy's life he wanted this bill let's
get it done now all sort of acrimonious
debate people from different regions
having different opinions let's put it
in the background let's get this done in
honor of John Kennedy that's a real
triumph that was really a great effort
by President Johnson without a strong
southern political leader like LBJ would
you been able to do it or would we have
been able to do it as quickly I don't
think so I think you really needed
someone like Lyndon Baines Johnson to
offer leadership and again I think
that's what's missing today Modesto
California good morning go ahead please
on it yeah good morning
ah I want nice places up it's a lot of
people don't know it if then I've never
nobody mention it but you know bright
people you stone white slaves to the
rich black in 1670 there's seven in
Virginia that row they had to free them
and then I have to still write when the
blacks is freed is the group of white
people brought the country hit right
there which is the captain man drove up
in there about four bypass and but even
today to send the black people back to
after they want to go but I can't
understand ice but American blocks of
some Americans brought my beer
and and the blacks back they wanted to
go but today to get a socialized
military Oh
I think uh oh there are merit area
this is a question Modesto California
would you pay to ship so uh but I just
I've been wanting that long I've never
nobody mentioned I wondered if he knew
about it
okay Modesto thanks for the call no I
don't let's go to Michigan Ann Arbor
Michigan good morning go ahead please
hi Dennis um I'm a former teacher and my
mother's a teacher
and one thing I do have to agree with
your guest about is that education is
the path if you will that's going to
break people away from the problems that
they're experiencing however where it
has to start is in kindergarten it has
to start in preschool it has to start
with parents that say yes we'll come to
PTA meeting it has to start with parents
who will sit down with their children
and we'll take them and say okay what
did you do in school today
it takes parents who if they don't have
the skills themselves of the parents
going back and learning the skills be it
arithmetic reading spelling role
modeling is what makes kids successful
in school and the most important role
models are their parents
I think that the caller is right on
target and of course they're writing
this book one thing that occurred to me
is that if black kids today really
understood all the pain and sweat and
tears that went into gaining the right
for black children to have access to the
best public schools the black children
would have a different attitude about
education education should be the
priority and for all black families for
all black people in it when you
understand that people work throughout
this whole century to develop strategies
that would one day allow black people to
get the best of in terms of public
education when you understand that james
Meredith risked his life to go to
University of Mississippi and establish
the president that black people should
be able to use at school you just get a
different sense of what education means
it suddenly becomes a very precious item
and a precious commodity Julian Bond
former Georgia state senator writes in
the introduction to eyes on the prize
quote but for most Americans a civil
rights movement began on may 17 1954
when the Supreme Court handed down the
Brown versus Board of Education of
Topeka decision outlawing segregation of
public schools the court unlocked the
door but the pressure applied by
thousands of men and women in the
movement pushed that door open wide
enough to allow blacks to walk through
it toward the country's essential prize
freedom inside the eyes on the prize
which is the book we're talking about
it's written by Juan Williams and it is
a and accompanies the six-part PBS
series on the civil rights movement Los
Gatos California good morning go ahead
please yes good morning gentlemen
morning I find it extremely dismayed to
observe blacks who have our so-called
made it socially economically or
politically ostracized isolate
themselves from blacks what they have
achieved is lofty position and million
even lose identity with their fellow
black brother which is something that's
also very distinct I don't think there's
any earth n-double-a-cp
or any other positive black affiliation
can do it this type of problem and I
think it were undermining ourselves I
like to ask your guest Peter um what
does he propose on changing these
attitudes of blacks every position well
you know I think the callers should take
a look at eyes on the prize the book in
the series because I think you'll see
that against tremendous odds in the in
its country's history black people and
white people and stood up and have
triumphs I mean you talk about in
entrench system we're talking about
segregation in this country not only
we're talking about maybe cultural
attitudes we're talking about the law
the law with segregation and if there's
a triumph there people really listed and
beat the odds and I think people can
beat the odds again in terms of the
middle class getting involved with
blacks I don't see why the n-double-a-cp
or urban league can't play a role and
somehow challenge channeling all the now
resources and educational experiences
and maybe even some of the success that
middle-class blacks have had back into
the
underclass that we see of poor blacks
and helping them to get to move up
because I think the call is exactly
right when he says that what we need is
for those middle-class blacks to really
go back down and help
Irving Texas go ahead please all right
yeah I just thought I want to make Frank
where the lady talked about earlier
about the parents being involved in the
education I think the educators have to
do a better job in affirming young
minorities father scholarships and loans
things that are available to minorities
to which they advance the college I
think you're not making the point these
kids there is life after they get out of
high school they're losing a lot of
children and you're on high schools the
dropout rate very high sufficient to
prevent panic and a lot of these gossips
and loans are even being used by renard
where there was $100,000 of minority
loans scholarships and grants of such
that are not even being used I'd like to
know human feelings about them well I
think that you're right that the black
children need to be informed of this I'm
really dismayed by the increasing number
of black dropouts we have in the nation
schools I'm a sort of disappointed to
see that you went through a blacks are
going to college now after we had done
such a great job as a nation of
increasing the number of blacks going to
school it's really a dismay it's a
despairing situation and I hope that
what you say comes to pass that the
teachers the educators make a real
effort to say to these kids you do have
a possible future in this country there
are black people who are successful in
this country
put your heart and soul into it you can
get it done let's say I just californ
you go ahead please as a white person I
like to put out there most people
welfare are white not black I like to
point out the reason we have increasing
racial violence is we add to that
demagogues like Ronald Reagan and Ed
Koch who like to play up to a mob and
don't care about the consequences of
future generations and the consequences
to this country and I thank you for your
time well you know I I think the color
is on to something there in terms of the
lack of political leadership I think in
both the case of Koch and President
Reagan there's a real
appeal to this sense of resentment
against blacks blacks getting too much
opportunity or affirmative action is too
much of a break for blacks the country
should be beyond that the country is not
beyond it then the country needs to
really sort of say squarely the issue
and to see that we have a glorious
history here this is the country that
from 54 to 65 is I right in eyes on the
prize when from a system that parallels
apartheid to a system that really said
you know if quality is an ideal for all
Americans black or white
let's work toward it and so I say let's
continue working toward it and get it
done earlier in the show you talked
about the year you spent writing this
book you went to several libraries
different places have have we done a
good job of saving memorabilia pictures
records of what took place between 54
and 65 I think in some cases we have now
Henry Hampton who's the head of black
side the executive producers a
television series tells me in some cases
he would find film footage thrown in a
basement sometimes he would come a day
late and someone say oh you know we had
that film footage about a month ago and
then someone threw it out in essence we
have some of it and we lost some of it
and I think it's really the imperative
now is to keep what we do have intact
because this is an amazing period of
history it's rather incredible to me
that we were just doing the book about
this point this is a really the first
comprehensive history of the movement
and I hope the people will take a look
at it and see that wonder in amazement
like I do that it hadn't been done
before where'd you get to title eyes on
the prize eyes on the prize comes from
an old civil rights song and I'm sorry
from an old gospel song and the gospel
song goes keep your eyes on the prize
hold on hold on and sort of hold on
through adversity and through all the
struggles that the black people have
seen in this country to keep their eyes
on the prize of freedom and dignity our
guest for last hour has been Juan
Williams author of this book eyes on the
prize America's civil rights years 54 to
65 writer with the post dividends in 76
now writes for The Washington Post
magazine won Williams thank you for your
time thank you